Despite performing poorly upon release both
critically and commercially, 1995's Empire
Records has gone on to become a coming-of-age
classic, gradually amassing a cult following
in the decades since.
For some of the cast members, Empire Records
was a launching pad for long and fruitful
careers.
For others, the beloved teen flick wound up
being their pinnacle.
Here's what the cast of Empire Records looks
like today.
Liv Tyler - Corey
After her rock star dad Steven Tyler cast
her in the music video for Aerosmith's hit
song "Crazy," Liv Tyler landed her first major
movie role as overachieving student Corey
in Empire Records.
Co-star Maxwell Caulfield later admitted that
the male cast members found it hard to keep
their eyes off this "emerging swan," prompting
Tyler's mother to remain on set so she should
could keep her daughter's admirers in check.
Since then, Tyler gained worldwide fame playing
Elf maiden Arwen in Peter Jackson's The Lord
of the Rings trilogy.
More recently she's starred as a regular on
the HBO series The Leftovers.
And she's moved into producing, pulling the
strings on the fantasy horror project Wildling,
which stars Tyler opposite Bel Powley and
Brad Dourif.
Coyote Shivers - Berko
While it's true that Liv Tyler's mother Bebe
Buell provided a chaperone service for her
daughter on set, there was actually a second
reason for her being there.
Buell married Berko actor Francis "Coyote"
Shivers in 1992, meaning that Tyler was acting
alongside her 24-year-old step-dad in Empire
Records with her mother watching over them
both.
Cool.
Shivers and Buell divorced in 1999 and he
has since worked as a musician and DJ in the
Los Angeles area, though his club work was
put on hold in September 2015 — when he
started a nine month prison sentence for violating
the terms of a restraining order filed against
him by his second wife, Pauley Perrette.
Renée Zellweger - Gina
After making her debut opposite fellow unknown
Matthew McConaughey in the 1994 flop Texas
Chainsaw Massacre: The Next Generation, Renee
Zellweger rebounded with a breakthrough role
as Gina in Empire Records.
She ended up riding that buzz to superstardom
in Jerry Maguire, and later won an Academy
Award for her performance in 2003's Cold Mountain.
Of course, everyone knows what Zellweger looks
like these days, because of an ongoing tabloid
controversy over whether or not she's had
plastic surgery to change her looks.
Zellweger has risen above the nonsense and
continues to perform in films like Bridget
Jones' Baby and Same Kind of Different as
Me.
Rory Cochrane - Lucas
Few young actors were as ubiquitous in the
'90s as Rory Cochrane, who appeared in ten
films that decade, including Dogtown and Dazed
& Confused, in addition to Empire Records.
These days he's best known for starring in
50 episodes of CSI: Miami as Timothy Speedle,
though he continues to appear on the big screen
as a character actor in films like Argo and
Black Mass.
Robin Tunney - Debra
With her shaved head, Robin Tunney caught
the attention of Hollywood as suicidal teen
Debra in Empire Records.
That led to roles in a string of big budget
blockbusters, but the gravy train derailed
when 2000's Supernova became a super flop.
Though she's continued to appear in minor
films since, Tunney has found more success
on the small screen, appearing in over 150
episodes of The Mentalist as Teresa Lisbon.
Ethan Embry - Mark
The definition of a working actor, Ethan Embry
has appeared in film and on television every
single year since Empire Records came out
in 1995 — even if you may not remember any
of those appearances.
While his most famous role is probably as
Rusty Griswold in Vegas Vacation, Embry is
still going strong with guest spots on shows
like The Walking Dead and Once Upon a Time.
Pretty good work if you don't mind getting
literally eaten alive.
Johnny Whitworth - AJ
Though he's best known for his role as AJ
in Empire Records, Johnny Whitworth almost
played a totally different character — he
initially wanted to play the part of Lucas
instead.
He told Starry Mag "I wanted to be Lucas because
he had great one-liners, but he didn't get
to kiss Liv Tyler at the end!
Everything comes together as God intends it."
"You're so special and you're so talented
and you've everything it takes you have more
than everything it takes and you're really
stupid because you don't know that."
Since then, the almighty has apparently intended
Whitworth to become a TV star, as he's had
recurring roles on CSI: Miami, The 100, and
Blindspot.
Anthony LaPaglia - Joe
Australian actor Anthony LaPaglia was a late
bloomer as a thespian, moving to New York
City in his early twenties in the hope of
one day becoming an actor.
By the late '80s he was regularly landing
gigs, eventually leading to his role as Joe
in Empire Records.
Since then, he's become most famous for his
Golden Globe-winning turn as suicidal FBI
agent Jack Malone in the CBS drama Without
A Trace.
"Superb."
"Say it again."
Maxwell Caulfield - Rex Manning
Washed up musician Rex Manning was the butt
of the joke in Empire Records, but actor Maxwell
Caulfield is anything but washed-up.
Though some may know him best for his role
as Manning, Caulfield has actually appeared
in nearly 40 feature films, while also working
on stage and providing voices for audiobooks,
cartoons, and video games.
Say no more.
"And you were my favorite singer in high school."
"Who's your favorite singer now?"
"You!
It's still you!"
Debi Mazar - Jane
Empire Records is just one many major motion
pictures where you may have seen Debi Mazar.
She's also appeared in films like Goodfellas,
Malcolm X, and Batman Forever.
She's since gone on to star in television
as well, with a recurring role as publicist
Shauna in Entourage.
If that weren't enough, she and her husband
Gabriele Corcos have their own show on the
Cooking Channel.
Brendan Sexton - Warren
Before playing Warren in Empire Records, Brendan
Sexton had already earned an Independent Spirit
Awards nomination for his role in Welcome
to the Dollhouse.
That was pretty much the highlight of his
career, though he continues to appear as a
character actor in ensembles like Black Hawk
Down, which he later publicly criticized for
the film's portrayal of Somalis.
James 'Kimo' Wills - Eddie
Not everyone is cut out to be a superstar.
Kimo Wills is one of those folks, as the guy
who played Eddie has since pretty much dropped
out of acting altogether after a string of
appearances as extras and other minor characters.
These days, he's just a normal dude doing
things like playing video games, reading comics,
and retweeting cute dog photos.
Hey, the world needs regular folks too!
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!